[Musique]
pour sois heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres
nous recevrons salma et mayadine la
référente ile de france des jeunes du
mouvement en marche
nous verrons avec l pourquoi les jeunes
se mobilisent derrière emmanuel macron
hier a eu lieu l'inauguration de
l'extension du centre de recherche inria
saclay situé à palaiseau
cette inauguration intervient au moment
où la cour des comptes épingle une
mauvaise gestion
la réponse du président de la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay avec michel
bournat nous recevons donc ça m'a ayadi
référente ile-de-france de la section
des jeunes avec emmanuel macron bon soir
dans ça selon les sondages votre
champion accéderait au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle moi j'ai une
question pourquoi vous l'avez rejoint
alors pourquoi j'ai rejoint emmanuel
macron tout simplement parce que pour la
première fois on a eu un candidat qui ne
ciblait pas des personnes c'est-à-dire
qu'il ne s'attendait pas à ce qu'il y
ait des personnes qui viennent d'un
milieu précis on qui en une origine
sociale précise il voulait juste tout
simplement que les personnes qui ont
envie de faire avancer la société puisse
le rejoindre
et aujourd'hui c'est un peu la volonté
de plusieurs jeunes c'est qu'on en a
marre de voir qu'il ya un certain
immobilisme sur or matière politique on
a envie que ça bouge on a envie que ça
avance soit beaucoup plus dynamique et
aujourd'hui c'est ce que emmanuel macron
représente et on voit aussi que beaucoup
de personnalités de gauche comme de
droite ce rallye elle lui comme aurore
bergé et lui les républicains de magny
les hameaux et responsables aussi de la
campagne d'alain juppé je vous propose
de découvrir
elle était hier dans notre journal
ça fait 40 ans que je m'engagerai à
droite et disons que le parc éolien de
gaz je me suis engagé à savoir d'abord
jeunes titulaires et sur des cas à
beaucoup que je me levais donc en
politique vous allé plusieurs fois
soit vous suivez aveuglément la ligne du
parti quelle qu'elle soit quelles que
soient les circonstances
soit vous allez là où sont vos
conduction ça va vous amener à absoudre
des gens différents
ou alors en carnet valeurs sont les
vôtres voit ses choix que je fais alors
on ne sait il n'ya pas encore
véritablement de programmes en tout cas
hélas pas divulguer provia c'est un
projet il ya certaines petits-enfants il
ya des indices au fur et à mesure mais
pour les jeunes concrètement qu'est ce
qui vous a attiré belle après la mesure
que je trouve vraiment essentielles
concernant les jeunes et pour commencer
la vie en société et pouvoir justement
davantage s'intégrer et et avoir
l'espoir d'intégrer un jour le marché du
travail c'est le pass culture avec avec
les 500 euros
décollant à 18 ans qu'on puisse accéder
que en fait c'est ça met sur un pied
d'égalité tout le monde à l'âge de 18
ans tout le monde aura l'accès à des
livres tout le monde aura l'accès à la
musique tout le monde aura accès à tous
ces éléments culturels que permettrait
le pass culture ça passe aussi par par
la suite l'émancipation par la troupe
par le travail la possibilité de se
libérer donc emmanuel macron veut
libérer le travail veut permettre à des
personnes et valoriser les personnes qui
travaillent d'être davantage comment
dire concrètement ça se
on ça se matérialise commencer non pas
du tout le travail par exemple
en dehors de l'entrepreneuriat
tamponnaise c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus précis mais beaucoup plus
largement c'est moins d'écart entre le
salaire brut et le salaire net par
exemple
donc ça c'est quelque chose de concret
c'est-à-dire que quand je travaillais
que j'ai une fiche de paie enfin qu on
me promet un salaire et que sur ma fiche
de paie un écart de 200 300 euros à sur
l'année c'est énorme et emmanuel macron
veut justement réduire cet écart entre
le salaire brut et le salaire net par
rapport aux retraites aussi il pense à
un module et ça peut être un peu plus 60
et 67 ans ça vous pose aucun problème
mais du tout dans la mesure où il ya
certaines personnes qui vont avoir un
travail qui va être beaucoup plus
pénible donc qui est qu'ils ne pourront
pas assurer très longtemps de travailler
et vous avez d'autres personnes qui sont
hyper satisfait qui ont encore l'énergie
pour travailler qui ont envie de
travailler de servir à quelque chose
dans le sens où d'efforts on peut se
sentir délaissés à partir du moment
entre dans la retraite et a toujours ce
sentiment de mais moi je ne sert plus à
grand chose
et du coup justement c'est simuler
relancer ce dynamisme que nous les
français nous avons et qu'on exploite
pas forcément et en ce qui concerne des
heures de travail seront beaucoup plus
flexible 35 heures ou même pour les
jeunes un peu plus et beaucoup moins
pour les plus anciens les seniors à 30
heures voire 32 heures et pour les
jeunes on pourrait arriver à 35,37 plus
probable aujourd'hui vous allez voir
n'importe quelle personne
on fait tous sur le marché du travail
elle est toujours plus que ce qui est
dans le contrat et on n'est pas toujours
payer pour ces horaires à la course
encore plus non pas du tout on serait
juste plus honnête sur la fiche de paie
et sur les horaires qui sont qui aurait
été effectivement qui ont été
effectivement travailler aller ont une
très courte phrase pourquoi les jeunes
rejoindre emmanuel max pour en une
courte phrase s'émanciper être plus
libre et surtout être maître de son
destin ce qui n'est pas aujourd'hui le
cas dans la société
eh bien merci madame el ayadi le 14
février 2017 a eu lieu l'inauguration de
l'extension du centre de recherche inria
saclay situé à palaiseau sur le plateau
paris-saclay 6000 mètres carrés ont été
créés pour accueillir de nouveaux
chercheurs dans l'enceinte cette
inauguration intervient au moment où la
cour des comptes a épinglé la mauvaise
gestion de paris-saclay écouter michel
bordas président de la communauté
d'agglomération de paris saclay
aujourd'hui on est à l'inauguration de
ce bâtiment
pourquoi êtes vous là et pourquoi est ce
important abbas est important tout
simplement parce que un des enjeux de
notre territoire et de développement du
pôle scientifique universitaire et
recherche et que l'inria fait partie des
établissements importants du territoire
qui ont contribué à la structuration de
la fondation de coopération scientifique
et de l'université paris 7 et de l'inria
étant à des membres fondateurs donc être
présent cette manifestation c'est
manifester en quelque sorte notre
soutien à l'inria en particulier mais au
projet dans son ensemble
paris saclay aujourd'hui ça représente
quoi à l'échelle internationale c'est
toujours difficile de donner des
chiffres à l'international
mais si on prend une référence parmi
d'autres et les mighty on est positionné
comme étant le huitième cluster à
l'échelle mondiale on a eu dernièrement
des résultats de la cour des comptes qui
disait que paris saclay était mal gérée
qu'est-ce que déjà quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à ça bon là
plusieurs remarques là la première s'il
faut remettre les choses dans le
contexte le projet paris cité c'est un
projet d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
c'est certainement une des plus grosses
opérations d'aménagement en france qui
touche au campus universitaire
scientifique qui touche à l'aménagement
du territoire à travers la création de
quartiers nouveaux important qui touche
au développement des transports a léché
de francilienne
donc c'est un contexte déterminant
apprécié le rapport de la cour des
comptes
il est ce qu'il est la cour est dans son
rôle quand elle pointe un certain nombre
de faiblesses
quant à aborder le développement du
projet moi ce que je regrette beaucoup
dans l'analyse qui a été faite par la
cour des comptes c'est qu'en fin de
compte on passe sous silence un certain
nombre de réussites comme le
je vais illustrer mon propos je fais
partie de ceux qui a maintenant sept ou
huit ans pourrait passer mon expression
pas parié un kopeck sur la capacité à
faire travailler entre des
établissements qui ont des identités
très fort pour polytechnique
l'université ceux là sont tous d état
dans l'état
si je voulais résumé la situation donc
de les faire travailler ensemble aussi
vite
aujourd'hui travaillent ensemble alors
il ya des il ya des phénomènes des
petites turbulences ici ou là certains
moments mais c'est la logique donc tous
les grands projets oui ces saisies dans
la rade que polytechnique était un peu
réticent oui mais au-delà de ça
aujourd'hui
le diplôme de docteur qu'il est délivrée
sous l'appellation université paris
saclay même chose pour les masters
l'attractivité du diversité paris-saclay
l'incontestable nombre de
d'étudiants qui sollicitent universités
pour participer à des masters a augmenté
de mémoire ces 28 ou 30 % au cours de la
dernière rentrée scolaire
donc il faut voir ces aspects positifs
donc la cour des comptes pointe des
faiblesses mais à côté de ça il ya des
enjeux qui sont le positif pour
l'université paris saclay et puis passer
sous silence et tous les enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire
il suffit de voir les grues sur le
territoire avec la réalisation des
projets de construction pour accueillir
les établissements d'enseignement pour
accueillir les étudiants pour accueillir
les futurs habitants pour accueillir les
entreprises selon vous le ce qui a été
fait ce compte rendu à cet instant t
n'est pas totalement fiable voire pas
fiable
j'irai pas pas fiable il y pointe d y
prendre des faiblesses mais il y a
beaucoup d'éléments positifs qui aurait
mérité d'être mis en avant et qui sont à
mon avis plus important que les
faiblesses criantes et souligné gène
dernière question ce rapport pointe
aussi le fait qu'il faudrait mettre une
nouvelle personne à la tête de paris
saclay en tout cas pour gérer tout ça
vous êtes d'accord
écoutez par définition fois un
coordinateur moi j'ai cru comprendre en
tant qu'élu local qui en a eu dans le
passé failli onnaing est actuellement
qui est le préfet de la région de france
qui est ma connaissance chargé de
coordonner le projet il y a par
définition l'établissement public
d'aménagement un qui est présidée par
valérie pécresse
il y a des partenaires aujourd'hui alors
que le gouvernement souhaite aujourd'hui
un moment ou un autre
renforcez effectivement la coordination
avec un délégué ministériel tu sais ce
dont on parle
vous n'êtes pas en a déjà vu bien il
peut y en avoir à demain ça change pas
fondamentalement les choses
ce qui compte c'est que tous les
partenaires un moment donné partage des
enjeux les la vision de l'aménagement
dans toutes ses composantes
c'est comme ça qu'on avance or qu'est un
coordinateur en chef parmi les autres
coordinateur dont acte mais c'est pas
forcément enjeu déterminant
je crois que la coopération quel lieu au
cours des derniers mois entre tous les
acteurs le démontre qu'on avance donc en
gros linoghin l'inauguration aujourd'hui
représente le travail de demain c'est ça
qu'il faut voir
abbas est une étape parmi d'autres dans
les enjeux de développement du cluster
scientifique et c'est important que les
élus puissent témoigner pour démontrer
que les choses avancent et sain bon
exemple ce jour et bien je vous remercie
mais je vous en prie c'est la fin de ce
set 8 les invités bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]